biden talking to hillary clinton for
potentially hillary clinton being on the
cabinet as the ambassador to the u.n
former national security adviser susan
rice said thursday that the reporting
president-elect joe biden is considering
hillary clinton
for u.s ambassador of the united nations
would be an insult to the former
secretary of state
meaning she deserves better than that
the thinking behind the move was that it
would be a way for biden to highlight
the importance of that position in his
administration
and are placing her there would rise the
prestige of the u.n itself at a time
when global cooperation and the u.s role
on the world stage has ebbed
the post-reported thoughts okay so
hillary's probably going why is susan
rice speaking for me i kind of want to
get out of the house
get away from bill i'll take any job in
the cabinet in the administration
uh it's wishful thinking he wants to
attach his wagon to hillary in some way
if this just came i know do you think do
you think
democrats when hillary lost do you
remember the media
on the left when hillary lost they all
slowly kind of took a step back
i don't know if you remember that or not
i mean there was a there was a
positioning from everybody like for
example
we're about to see it with republicans
look how many people today when they
said trump lost
everybody was waiting someone on the
right to come out and the first person
it took a day
it was lindsey graham saying i paid 500
000 to the legal
nobody was saying anything yes newt was
some of the but everybody else stayed
silent so
in a way republicans are also showing
their colors
they're showing their colors to say look
if trump lost we're kind of staying on
the outside now ted cruz defended him
but a lot of other guys are like if he
lost he lost right let's go and
you know kind of step away why bring
hillary clinton back
is there a hillary clinton audience for
biden to want to win over
well i think she's a brand and she's a
democratic brand and there's a place
for her probably in his administration i
think susan rice is saying
something bigger so i think she's
validating the fact that she should have
an even bigger role
such as so i know you're a big fan of
hillary that's why i'm asking you so
a cabinet position you know something
much bigger than that
and i'm not sure what it would be um
she's already been the secretary of
state i mean she doesn't need to do that
again
but she's not just going to fade away
she has to stay relevant she has to stay
out there somehow plus they're going to
be taking this victory lap for four
years
if they can so everybody's going to be
front and center one day that would be a
bad move for them to take a victory lap
for four years because four years from
now biden's going to be 82
and i'm not sure in what state he's
going to be at 82
and if you do take a victory lap for
eight years and nothing gets done what's
going to be worse is in two years you
lose house
and if you lose house the way you do
then you're you can't get nothing done
because you're at gridlock
and so if you lose house and you don't
have senate then that means in four
years
someone on the right could potentially
come and take it away from you but
hillary wants to be involved i mean she
became a senator and went through
everything that you have to do to be
elected i mean she's not comfortable
just fading away
right that's i have zero respect for her
really yeah that's um
however and i still maintain contacts
with some of the special operations
units here in the united states and
just i mean the the incident that's
always out there is benghazi
and she could have saved people by just
making one phone call issuing one order
for a c-130 gunship to come in and save
those people
we lost an ambassador not just special
operators we lost an ambassador because
of that
because the decision wasn't made or the
decision was made as a no-go
that's not your responsibility your
responsibilities protect americans
i don't think she's on the most liked
list when you think about poli
if you were to put right now the most
hated politician today
politician who would you put at the top
of the list who would you want ahead of
her oh you mean on the democratic side
no i mean period left and right
would you put trump one if trump is one
who's number two
probably hillary yeah because she's so
polarizing do you think she's number two
i think so probably who's third left or
right
who's third most hated mcconnell pelosi
pelosi i voted for pelosi yeah
mcconnell's not like title by the way
they're both on this but she's just more
high profile so i think that she's
probably got more haters
the other thing too is you know
everything's about favors at this point
you know so what whatever deal hillary
has in place already to serve
you know in some positions she's got
that i mean she's going to be there i
know i know you wrote an article
yesterday on vtpose.com
with freedom of speech being at the
question right now with some hate speech
where
freedom of speech they want to kind of
change the first amendment because
to categorize some things isn't free
you're not you shouldn't have the
freedom to say just anything
something should be categorized as hate
speech right so this is a member of
biden's transition team yeah that uh
has a media affairs job and he's saying
there's some problems with the first
amendment
now the reason that i believe that you
know this thing's not going to go
anywhere is because he's getting
from both sides you know so very
controversial thing but i think the
bigger picture is it's just another day
it's another radical thing that we're
hearing that they want to potentially
throw out there as a trial balloon and
see where it goes
or ultimately make a change they keep
talking about everything that they can
do on the first day it's frightening
when you start looking at that list
so look freedom of speech is there for a
reason there's a reason it's the number
one
you know bill of right so um
they would be in uh you know some
serious trouble if they tried to do
anything with that it's just not a
priority it shouldn't be something that
they should try to attack right away
[Music]